[Música]
[Aplausos]
Oh
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Oh
[Música]
de seus amores
não deles terminou
[Aplausos]
eu sou facebook
[Música]
é brasil
Bah
Oh
[Música]
eu
e eu trago aqui merece
[Aplausos]
ou não
S
isso está errado
mas
é difícil
a professora
mas
assim
de suas camas
mais
está falando de precisão
nerd
vamos ver
S
dela
peguei um pouco
Itália
S
disso
[Música]
isso
sim
de seus amores
nerd
a festa
o amor
agora
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Oh
tipo de som esfregado
não somos batucadas chegou
ou dias de uma visita nossa gente
redes sociais e com isso melhor
projeto que queríamos pensar
grupos de organizações especializadas
e obrigado e você me fez com rapidez
um freio de folha esteja aqui
feliz com esta festa
talvez os dados de navegação estivessem tentando
sufocar
vamos as pessoas até o último ponto positivo
mais registros e não vamos descer ao
Next
[Música]
dois
assim
também pede
eu sei
com ele
[Aplausos]
r
e eu quero que ele vá comigo
dois
não
não quero
ao dia
sim
cerca de metade
O que
do meu corpo
e perdido
como eu disse
com você
e que
ontem
não se vêem
mas não me veja
d
não quero ser
e comigo
[Aplausos]
sim Sim
Figueira
a carabina
[Aplausos]